martine michel et michel c'est bon soir
alors la vérificatrice générale madame
leclerc qui est très claire dans son
rapport qui est décourageant nous dit
l'accès un médecin une famille non
seulement ne s'est pas améliorée depuis
trois ans ça s'est détériorée et pour
s'inscrire c'est une chose
et pour être vue par un médecin c'est
encore plus long 404,5 soixante dix
jours en moyenne donc plus d'une année
je veux entendre madame leclerc d'une
mare des mimiques on a mis beaucoup
d'argent pourtant on ajouter de l'argent
on écoute qu'elle nous disons ministère
était contrôlé les sommes que vous
versez en vous assurant qu'ils ont une
efficacité si rendez vous santé québec
pour quelques raisons que ce soit pour
les deux parties ce n'est pas la
solution mais qu'on en trouve une autre
solution mais faut pas oublier que
rendez vous santé québec ont investi 15
millions de dollars et seulement 6% des
médecins utilisent je disais à aulas
michel c'est au juge commencé avec vous
on le projet de loi 20 à l'origine
devait y avait la carotte de l'argent
qui avait le bâton
or on a enlevé le bas at on a gardé la
carotte l'honneur résultat la piste et
les citoyens qui se font avoir
c'est cher la carotte ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est qu'une fois que vous
êtes inscrit sur un médecin de famille
ça fait un an et demi pour avoir les
premiers rendez vous ça c'est ça qui
n'était pas prévu dans le système et moi
de nous disaient ils vont être vues de
façon raisonnable avec un délai
raisonnable ça c'est totalement
raisonnable non seulement la première
partie ne marche pas c'est difficile
d'avoir un médecin de famille
c'est difficile d'avoir le premier
rendez vous étonnez vous pas que ça
avant l'urgence quand même comme
vérificateur général mais est ici c'est
pâques c'est important et 70 pour ça des
gens qui vont devrait pas y aller
devrait jouer dans un cabinet de médecin
et donc quand monsieur legault nous
parle d'un système qui est à presque
rupture ça a pas mal d'années maintenant
clairement c'est le premier rendez vous
est un problème et signaleraient que le
deuxième puis le troisième
les délais sont peut-être pas aussi long
mais ça peut aussi être un problème
quand vous avez un problème de santé
sans être une urgence mais qui pour vous
et incommodant même à trois semaines
d'avis et c'est un peu long et les gens
se retrouvent en urgence
honnêtement moi quand l'entente est
intervenue avec les médecins la
fédération des omnipraticiens
particulier qui nous avait assuré que
telle on n'a pas besoin d'un bâton là
nous on sait comment s'organiser on
assure que les gens vont être couverts
et qui vont avoir accès à leur médecin
on les a cru sur parole
de toute évidence la marchandise et paul
ivry alors je ne sais pas quelle est la
solution parce que il y en a beaucoup de
solutions qui ont été essayées jusqu'à
présent mais y est fort possible qu'il
faille revenir au bâton tout l'état
double pénalité dans le camp des
médecins exactement à quoi il s'était
engagé
xi a pas de suivi par exemple dans le
mois s'il ya pas de rendez vous bien une
pénalité et c'est martin sens avait été
prévu à l'origine ce avait été laissé
tomber puis le bureau du 1er mai ce
critère était intervenu à l'époque pour
adoucir un peu tout seul
oui ben est en fait personne en fait
visiblement au gouvernement de philippe
couillard et même au gouvernement de
monsieur le goon voulait utiliser le
bâton mais là on arrive finalement à
échéance et on regarde les résultats le
bâton il est encore utilisable dans
l'entente
mais sincèrement est-ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un au québec qui pensent que le
ministre de la santé présentement c'est
sa priorité de mettre les omnipraticiens
ou pas il n'y en a pas mal dans son
assiette mais d'ici demain il va un jour
il va bien falloir régler cette
situation là parce que les urgences sont
engorgés on parle de la pression sur le
système de santé qui fragile et là si la
pandémie prend
on continue dans si les chiffres
continuent à monter on va avoir besoin
du système de santé
oui d'ailleurs monsieur dubé a été
appelé à commenter plus a dit que y est
il y avait deux rencontres prévues dans
les deux prochaines semaines avec la
fédération des médecins omnipraticiens
puis que oui c'était une priorité parce
que même c'est pas la coved scellier
d'une certaine façon si on peut
désengorger les urgences bien savoir
apaiser moins d'infirmières bon répondu
j'ai eu beaucoup il y en a eu beaucoup
des rencontres avec les médecins ballon
comment s'est rendu au bâton bon et on
commence est rendu à des signes
d'impatience monsieur legault vous faire
entendre en chambre sur cette histoire
du traçage puis les oppositions le parti
québécois et québec solidaire ne veulent
pas recommander aux gens de s'inscrire
alerte qu'ovide voici ce que ça donne
québec solidaire refuse d' inciter les
québécois à s'inscrire une application
une question de vie ou de m'en tiens
québec solidaire et le parti québécois
vont être leurs responsabilités si la
santé publique nous transmet
l'information à l'effet que cette
application ne congestionne repas les
tests de dépistage et donc les réponses
à nos concitoyens concernant les
résultats du dépistage le dit qu'on
serait prête à temps mais on ne veut pas
nous donner accès à sort c'est le
directeur la santé publique lui confirme
qu' aucun impact sur le traçage
d'inciter québécois s'inscrire avant de
suggérer ce sac à vienne nous dire
j'espère qu'à voir respecter sa parole
chavez qu'est ce que ça vous dit cette
scène vers samedi depuis le début de la
semaine que monsieur leubou s'impatiente
un peu plus chaque jour et je le
comprends mais c'est aussi un signe
d'impuissance messieurs le goût ne sais
plus et son gouvernement aussi ne sait
plus à quel point se vouer
dans le cas du l'application de traçage
j'avoue que je trouve que l'opposition
cherche des problèmes aux solutions
je pense que cela soit la solution à
tous les problèmes mais il semble que ça
peut plus à aider que nuit où il ya une
commission parlementaire
en août dernier les libéraux états
comptent maintenant ils sont pour et je
pense que les arguments qui ont été
avancés par le gouvernement depuis au
cours du dernier mois incite à donner la
chance au coureur
et j'entendais encore monsieur dubé qui
disait compter le problème de bip de
l'engorgement du tt cliniques de
dépistage par les gens qui auraient eu
un avertissement par leurs applications
c'est moins un problème maintenant c'est
le traçage qui pose un problème et
l'application peut aider dans le traçage
haras au total il me semble que
l'opposition l'a beaucoup d'autres
sujets dans le cas de la commune on
aimerait me semble que celui là et il ya
plein d'autres
clouston l'est sur lesquelles ils
peuvent frapper pas nécessairement celui
là mais ça manque comme vous dites bien
que ce une période difficile plein le
temps façon des faits michèle c'est là
que j'ai vu qu'eric solidaire avait
finalement donné son appui à ses droits
merci dernière ils se confient la
lumière cela dit cette application là
elle était très quand lui la commission
parlementaire au module a été très
critiquée tout ça même le gouvernement
disait nous on préfère avoir une app
québécoise chez benjo devront travailler
là dessus
à la fin j'avais arrivée 7 à plat et là
c'est un c'est un moyen qui est utile et
même si une feuille d'érable
l'usap le marché alors pourquoi ne pas
s'en servir alors je comprends pas
qu'elle est là qu elle était l'objection
de québec solidaire et du pq depuis je
jeûne que le pq va se rendre compte de
deux sont aussi abandonnées parce que
dans une situation comme celle là on
prend tous les moyens cette année un oui
martin beaucoup d'esbroufé des partis
d'opposition dans cet épisode là et
quand parti québécois dit on est pour le
libre-choix en fait défoncer une porte
ouverte parce qu'il n'y a jamais été
question de forcer tout le monde à
utiliser cette application là c'est déjà
les bras tous québec solidaire
finalement attendait juste le pouce en
l'air de ratio arruda pour changer
d'idée se rendant bien compte que c'est
avait pas grand bon sens pin
monsieur legault bain et comme michel le
disais il est un peu dépassé de 5 ans
est très impatiente on ne peut pas lui
reprocher de proposer un outil plus
moderne que le fax
c'est après sa fille disait là
franchement on a fait des efforts les
embarquer je vais vous montrer la carte
du québec russie ont la carte toute la
vallée du saint laurent est en rouge
maintenant c'est annoncé en fin d'après
midi à trois rivières trois rivières
dont quittant rouge c'est pas celle là
c'est les régions en rouge que je
voudrais trois-rivières kaki et un rouge
mort ici et là martin je repense avec
vous le tour de table mais la question
était posée par un journaliste
c'est bien beau mais quand je croise les
doigts que sa réelle demande pas parce
qu'après le rouge à quoi on confine mais
85% de la population c'est pas mal tout
le monde sera en fait on va protéger
saguenay-lac-saint-jean va protéger
aussi la côte nord mais il ya un
mouvement qui est en train de
s'organiser au québec et on le voit en
gaspésie louis ii ya des directions de
santé publique régionale qui mettent des
mesures d' un peu plus corsée en zone
orange dans leur propre région pour
essayer d'éviter le rouge parce que le
roux je veux dire fermer les bars les
restaurants et des conséquences pour les
élèves du secondaire a lancé si les
régions commencent à s'organiser
commencent à prendre le problème en
amont parce que ça se fait moins bien au
niveau national où il estime que ça se
fait moins bien au niveau national mais
là c'est certain que on a moyen le sens
du québec la mauricie et la capitale
nationale qui
qui est qui et sur le frein qui confine
i way et michel david c'est ça c'est
qu'on veut vraiment que les prochains
jours montrent une stabilisation l'on
pense pas que ça va des savoirs bien
c'est très rapidement au moins de
stabilisation puisque après là on veut
même pas imaginer après c'est justement
c'est la question
patrice c'est que quand tout le monde
doit être dans le rouge depuis que ça
continue à augmenter à partir de quel
moment on entre dans noir et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire le noir si les mesures
qui ont été imposées jusqu'à présent ne
fit ne suffit dispo il est clair qu'il
va falloir passer à autre chose
et d'ailleurs je pense que monsieur
rideau qui le dit un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui bas il va falloir tout va
confirmer alors c'est la première fois
me semblait-il que on commence à évoquer
même pour dire qu'on veut pas en venir
là mais la possibilité qu'on re confine
comme au printemps dernier les écoles à
peu près toutes les entreprises d'un
essentiel alors il me semble que
maintenant le ja ja comme penser du bien
préparons-nous ça pourrait arriver ouais
vous le dites pour un vertige déjà à
cette pensée là à michel c'est toute
cette histoire des codes de couleurs
c'est dépassé aubenas où c'était hausse
a été là c'est tout le monde s'est
retrouvé dans le rouge extrêmement
rapidement alors déjà c'est quelque
chose de plus utile parce que 85% de la
population est là ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que l'erc la maladie
continue de ceux de se propager
rapidement à se propage à des endroits
où à se propager un port avant et il va
falloir probablement prendre des mesures
supplémentaires c'est à peu près évident
qu'on s'envoie là qu'est ce que ça va
mais je ne sais pas mais il il ya
certainement très bien on a rarement vu
ça un premier ministre qui désavouent
tête le verbe est un peu trop fort mais
en tout cas en chine qui publiquement ne
réitère pas sa confiance dans la mine
est ce la milice il vit d'amour qui est
sur la sellette on écoute monsieur
lavaud je trouve s'avance pas assez vite
les suite aux recommandations
du rapport vient je vais m'impliquer
personnellement on comprend donc vous
n'avez plus confiance en votre ministère
et un ensemble de raisons pourquoi ça
avance pas plus vite le chef picard lui
refusait y a dans les minutes qui annulé
des rencontres jeudi peut pas négocier
seul il faut avoir quelqu'un le côté de
la table personne monsieur legault pour
occuper ce poste là avant de rêver je
tenterai de regarder les sites us
j'ai en train de regarder la situation
sur moi je serai la ministre d'amour
mais ça y est elle lancée par dessus
bord martin oui il n'est pas satisfait
ça c'est clair
il ya des bonnes chances qu'elle ne
survivent pas au prochain remaniement
je pense pas qu'il va faire un
remaniement maintenant là mais parce que
quand même n'est pas un petit ministre
senior
mais c'est clair que c'est un désaveu
elle ne faisait pas partie de son
premier choix quand il a formé son
cabinet il ya deux ans monsieur legault
elles étaient allaités longtemps au
ballottage la cl a plaidé beaucoup pour
accéder au cabinet monsieur legault
voulait un cabinet paritaire il a pris
elle était lui est faite elle était avec
lui depuis 2014 a décidé de la prendre
mais évidemment son mandat c'était de
livrer c'est à dire de livrer la
marchandise et on voit bien que c'est
vrai ça oui michel david michels et en
même temps la piste et j'ai la même
réflexe que j'ai eue lors de notre
discussion sur madame blais ya des mois
de ça au mois de juin dernier
c'est pas un peu facile parce que les
grandes priorités du verlan c'est le
bureau du premier ministre et donne à
l'époque c'était rené lévesque qui
négociaient nation à nation et là bon je
dis pas que c'est la meilleure mine est
ce que j'en sais rien en fait
mais il n'y a pas quelque chose
d'injuste lada michel david ce que
madame blais est le pouvoir d'un
ministre est peu importe laquelle dans
un gouvernement il est celui que le
premier ministre d'un bien lui lui
conférer est évident que dans le cas de
la ministre responsable des acteurs elle
en a pas beaucoup mais il le premier
ministre actuellement et de façon
générale comme beaucoup d'autres nous
aussi qui lui apparaissent prioritaires
plus que celui des autochtones il ya des
périodes de crise bien entendu mais
pendant ce temps là il faut que
quelqu'un de cm2 fort et il a ça prend
quelqu'un qui précisément parce que pas
de pouvoir a beaucoup doit être capable
de faire patienter de maintenir le
dialogue donc d'être reconnu comme un
saint
un interlocuteur crédible par les
communautés autochtones
or c'est pas le cas de madame d'amour
c'était le cas de jeff kelly c'était le
cas de guy chevrette
mais depuis le début la cc c'est pas
nouveau que les autochtones oui chef
autochtone this que madame d'amour c'est
pas une interlocutrice qui considèrent
comme étant de leur niveau
alors c'était je pense une mauvaise
série charles c'est la fin de l'histoire
puisque même martine zahia prendre
remaniement qui vient comment peut-être
même resté dix jours encore de quatre
auditions ministre du fait des boîtes
c'est assez évident dans dix jours dans
vingt jours je ne sais pas mais mais sa
proue aussi une chose d angle mort de
monsieur legault il a tendance à nommer
des gens là d'autres s'occuperont
s'est-elle comme on l'a viendra demain
ça fonctionne mais peut-être encore
celle que vos affaires autochtones faut
pas faire ça parce que c'est dos et
l'homme on vous revenir dans la figure
inévitablement une chaîne david parlait
jeff kelly qui était pas de mine est le
plus flamboyant mais qui était à son
affaire il était capable d'aller parler
à tout ce monde là
la dame d'amour de toute évidence nos
ports les atomes crochus qu'il faut pour
parler à ses assesseurs prêtons les
supplices qui absorbe alors c'est cruel
mais ça c'est vrai faut que je me le
répète
merci au revoir au revoir aux seniors